how being ugly is a
blessing how being ugly is a blessing
look at me look look all my blackheads
look at that look at my hairline look
how pale I am I almost become invisible
as I as I walk back true story right see
let's define
ugly we know what ugly is not you're not
ugly you're average at
worst is this your man
ugly uh yes just by some some people
centered yeah he is so General we're
talking about in general Society some
people individually yes on average you
think this guy's getting below a Five
Below a
five hold
up I almost become invisible it all
depends on how tall he is and [__] like
that but yeah I think he could get a a
four mhm depending for some people mhm I
don't think he's like like horrid I've
seen some horrid people like this sh is
all jacked up I'm not I wouldn't give
him a two I only give him three but he
know it's fine it's okay you're not ugly
you're not even close to it you're at
best a worst average and you're probably
going to be hovering around five sixes
and sevens some people are even going to
find your look so different they're
going to weight you way way way higher
too because the fact you got blonde hair
and pale skin there's going to be some
people who are into that good build you
think a few people think he's ugly I
think most people just think he's just H
when you say ugly you're talking about
people who are actually like revolting
that he's that we're talking about
[__] Quasimoto from the last cut
video
that's an ugly person you see ugly and
revolting okay if there's ugly average
and attractive revolting is like a
different level of ugly that's very very
very ugly you can be ugly and not be
revolting when you're saying ugly you're
going to twos threes and ones if I could
get ugly in my worst my worst case what
do you think your rating is my rating is
about a six quasi normal day I could go
I could climb up to like if I dress nice
and everything and got the nice cologne
and stuff like that I could climb up to
eight if I talk about the world I could
climb to a low eight generally you take
care of yourself so you're hovering
between the six and seven cuz you're
most of the time you take care of
yourself sure okay so that's where
you're at that's like where your score
is generally okay so you're not ugly
you're about you're above average maybe
it's because I've been with people who
I've been around people who are very
ugly I've been around like the nerdy
side of the world I've been around like
people were social Rejects and spend all
their days I want to be a Discord mod
okay that's people I see them [__] is
ugly there like I don't think you
understand the birth the wide birth
between you and those people that's why
when I hear say that you're saying that
it's not even an insult no no no no no
no no it HS to look at some of them God
damn no no no it is it is it is What
hurts the most is that it's not even
when he says it like that it's not an
insult no no because it's just like bro
it comes from a place of n n you could
you got fight and I leaving you to fight
but you're not doing uphill [__] it's
straight up parallel like you better
walk on wall Spider-Man cuz you the
climb you got to make okay Stephen
Hawking you got to make a steep okay I
hope you have some breaks on them reals
I look at some people and I'm like bro
your biggest issue is that you're just
average okay so you think this guy's
average he's got a good build he he he's
got a very good build wide shoulders and
you know what the thing he got going for
him is he got an interesting face he got
a face you can H but stare at it not for
the wrong reasons either it just looks
different like he's got like
traditionally afro Afrocentric features
but because because of the the thing
that makes people albino right he got
that going on he's got the hairline that
it's proceeding so it's not like you got
balling issues no you can you can do
something with that yeah exactly it's
like you your hairline is just too far
forward cut the [__] nobody cares
that's not a real problem I can't I
can't do this no matter how much I do
this it's not coming forward unless I
want to get that myin hair trans plan
it's just not going to happen no it's
not okay okay it's like your hair has to
grow you're not ugly listen I was ugly
for a long time but that's because I
self-sabotaged okay I just have to hold
that okay okay I did I I just s sabotage
like I was I was being stupid okay and
even during my self sabotage No Good
Reason listen I acknowledge why like why
we don't need to get into my for no good
reason my guy sometime [__] I
pick you up and then you sit in my car
and I'm like why are you doing this Hey
listen it it don't even matter you want
know why it don't matter cuz they
still so I say if it ain't broke don't
fix it but moving past that why are you
doing this I'm saying some people
magnify their own rejections in life and
then really harp on those to think like
it's a real reflection of how most
people feel about I think there's a
certain segment of the population that
overestimate I'm a 10 shut up stupid
you're not even close okay you're not
and there's some people who are just
like I'm I'm super up it's like no and
yeah I'm like hovering to average to
above average I'm okay with that that's
we good some of
y'all some of yall are ugly but a lot of
y'all are just average and the thing
about being average is like you're kind
of coasting you can get some
dates but you don't have the experience
of really attractive people so you're
like oh oh I'm not them I must be ugly
it's like no trust me ugly people's
existence is just built different the
idea of being like a th% invisible a lot
of you don't know it you're not
invisible [__] you're in in your home
people can't see you cuz you're not
outside so all this to say he's starting
off the video saying why it's great to
be ugly I'm like my guy the guy from the
other video who
said uh what was that video my
experience being ugly yeah he's ugly and
he still found a girl and they still
together shout out to you he was ugly
God bless him there was things he could
do to improve himself absolutely but
that's ugly is he close to that no
that's all I'm saying listen it's good
to be self-critical but don't be so self
critical that you're just like now
mocking people ugly is not what's on
Vogue ugly is not what's on you know GQ
that's not ugly Society has a standard
and everybody who does not meet that
they fall short and the further along
you get in terms of how you look
physically you become more and more ugly
the for the further you look from GQ the
further you look from you know uh
whatever women's magazine there is
you're ugly and that's how the world
will see you and that's how Society will
treat you and I and I'm I'm standing
here to explain to you how I was treated
as such I'm ugly now I am okay with the
way I look you know I think I look I
think I look good you know a little bit
you know but I understand that in a way
I am ugly
because even further from how everybody
can see there's a natural way of things
I am not that I am not the natural look
I stick out there's a difference between
being ugly and being different I know
tall model like women who up until end
of high school were making fun of and
then right after they graduate they're
getting runways in Paris right they were
made fun of as being Giants or long
lanky legs and a super self-conscious
there's a difference between different
and ugly I understand what you're saying
and you're perfectly right the problem
is what he how he was treated the end
result he was treated the same way as he
uglies so to him it doesn't make any
difference and he can see and I believe
that according to his experience he
could say that he's ugly because he
lived that experience as well when I
grew up it was
everybody treats me like I'm radioactive
some people would come to come in
contact with me some people would want
to get to know me but mostly everybody
around me especially in elementary
school it was almost like being around
me was dangerous to their health it was
it was like being around
me um tainted their reputation
as a social in a social hierarchy sense
like if you were a cool person hanging
around with me was not cool because look
look at look at I look like a freaking
like one of the mushrooms you see in
your garden growing the white ones or
like an iPod charger something yeah
that's crazy he said that [__] I'm like
I see it now I see it I don't know oh
[__] hey Super Mario that's crazy he do
look like one of the Mario mushrooms the
ones that you use to get a little speed
boost
oh just
like that wow I I never heard that
that's funny that's funny that's funny
at a young age I got to understand that
like I got to understand just how
naturally evil people are because they
only really care about
themselves because hanging around me
even though we would laugh and even
though we would be friendly with each
other because you didn't want other
people to look at you a certain way oh
we can't hang out that's just one
example but how was that a blessing how
is that a blessing because what it
taught me at a young age is
that people are very fickle and they
will they will turn their back on you
your friends will do it people you just
people you just meet people will be
insulting they they'll hurt you for no
reason well they might they might have
the reasons but it doesn't necessarily
matter what the reasons
are but it's okay because I also got to
experience friends who I still know to
this day in the elementary school who
stuck with me from kindergarten
literally to now I know people who
are not like that so there's a
dichotomy but I didn't I didn't I didn't
go to saying oh man I hate these people
you know saying I can't believe people
are like that why why why does the world
have to be like this and then all of a
sudden I I shoot up a school or all of a
sudden I become um you know hurtful to
others because I'm trying to inflict how
I'm feeling on them Americans are wild
bro yeah listen y'all call me super
listen I'm a good person I I didn't blow
this place up like how did come through
with that AR and give you that spray
baby like I'm a good person
level level you just said they didn't
like you your
level
Americans hey it's a blessing because
God kind of like showed me like look
it's it's all right man it's okay it's
okay to what it's okay to not be
accepted by the group and this is the
point of this video see everybody wants
to be accepted everybody seeks
validation because as I'm ugly I
understand that it's okay to not be
accepted people didn't like me in high
school in kindergarten in college right
now at the Walmart I want to whenever I
sit on a bus stop people don't like me
because the way I look but some will but
most importantly it's okay because I'm
not dead yet no one accepts me a lot of
people don't accept me people run away
from me people Gunk at me CU of my skin
color but it's okay I can speak what's
morally right I can I can say I can tell
people the truth because I don't care
about the consequence of how they feel I
can be who I need to be and who I'm
supposed to be and who I know God wants
me to be all you Attractive people are
fake as [__] that's what he's
essentially saying uglies are the real
truth
tellers that's essentially what he's
getting
at cuz he doesn't care I don't care
about your feelings
cuz you don't care about cuz you don't
care about mine you don't care about
mine yeah [__] you you didn't care about
mine and God sent me for you to suffer
my wrath so you will know by the truth
that you is a piece of garbage I have a
confidence because I'm ugly I have a
confidence that I I've been with people
with with women who are very pretty but
they are the most
insecure
see all this I'm ugly
talk I'm ugly I've been with super hot
women who are met insecure yeah I've
been with the hottest but you've been
with them because they're
insecure any it's carry on schizophrenic
people you'll ever meet they they they
don't like themselves and I don't get it
it's like the most weirdest thing some
of the most attractive women are like
they're the most fragile things on the
planet in the mind in the spirit in the
heart because they don't know their life
their life exists in a vacuum of
validation it's too black and white for
me it's too black and white you know
sometimes I think you you think you live
on one side yeah I know black and white
I know it's funny with his albino stuff
but you live on one side and then you
just make this caricature of Attractive
people like oh all Attractive people are
insecure or they don't like themselves
or they can't say the truth it's like no
there's plenty of Attractive people who
are very giving considerate kind
passionate people who are full of
confidence and it's not just built off
their looks and there's some ugly people
who is also ugly on the inside they're
they're as ugly on the outside as they
are on the inside they're just vile
human beings okay all right you know we
have this idea ugly people are the ones
we always have to root for they're The
Underdogs no I know ugly people are just
[__] [__] people all right and vice
versa being part of one Camp does not
make you a good person just because you
struggled and you were made fun of does
not mean that you're like some good
person underneath some of y'all just bad
people too this not a Disney movie no
it's not like that it's not like I've
met some attractive women who are some
of the sweetest human beings and they're
always consistent that they've been that
their entire lives but I think we make
these characters because we're not part
of one club we need to ostr the other
one and then make them come down
right all rich people all these money
grubbing it's just not the case and
there's some poor people out there that
y'all know are just trash they're
stealing they're beating people up
they're graping folks it is what it is
watching this guy's video it just felt
like everyone's in one camp or the other
and that to me I don't think is just
very honestly reflective it just sounds
like you're speaking from a place of
hurt and you want to kind of
pejoratively speak about the other
side that's not the point but that's
what you end up doing
yeah anyways you still think he's really
ugly now that you've heard the whole
thing
nope I'm just saying that dude I I I I
looked him for two seconds and if you
told me a guy with a bunch of a hot
women I would not be shock the other guy
from the other video my ugly my
experience if you have told me him I'd
have been like yo we need some
investigat where the CIA yeah we need to
go get the feds on this cuz I don't
understand how this is
happening so I'm just trying to say
there's levels to
everything I know sometimes people want
to claim they nerds but really they just
watched a few marble movies it feels
like some people want to claim they ugly
cuz they got rejected sometimes chill
you're not ugly you're just human people
say no and also if your ugly experience
is really just what happened in uh when
you were in school and stuff like that
you're no longer than that no more you
know what I mean a lot of people are
ugly back then so it's like our heads
nearly like three times the rest of our
body when that's not a real proportion
you know what I mean uh other than that
so you talking about oh yeah I'm ugly
I'm ugly I'm ugly I'm ugly I'm ugly
that's uh presense and then why you ugly
well cuz when I was a kid it don't
that's that was the past tell me why
you're ugly now tell me why you're ugly
now all because you know the magazine
and this and that actually and sometimes
in the vogs there is sometimes people
that look like you and they are models
you know people that have like a a lot
of freckles because they get out of
there and they become models people that
are not in they not in the the spectrum
of what we think they still look good
because they appealing they have an
appealing Fai tell me why now if the
most of your explanation is from back
then then that don't really count no
that don't really count as for now yeah
maybe you was ugly back then but what do
you know when you a kid you don't even
dress your goddamn self you don't you
don't even make your lunch a good point
you don't even make your you don't dress
yourself you don't so there's a lot of
things there's a lot of factors around
you that makes that you're ugly but
really it's not ugly or not ugly it's
privilege or not okay and so right now
tell me now yeah I I think I figured it
out go ahead I think we're all living
our own experience as like a first
person protagonist type thing and then
our reference is always in reference to
like Attractive people cuz they're the
ones we see in the media they're the
ones we see on magazine and they're the
ones we see on social media and we're
like I'm not living that life I'm not
getting their kind of response if I'm
not part of their Club I must inherently
be part of the ugly Club cuz I'm not in
that triod yeah but the realization is
like most of us are somewhere in the
middle yeah you get what I'm trying to
say yeah cuz the downtrod and the truly
poor people the ones you'll never really
get to witness unless you go to some of
these [__] slumps you don't know
their experience you live somewhere here
in the Middle where you still got issues
but you don't got this bottom tier but
you also don't have this one because
you're not here at the top layer right
of the cake
you feel like you must be straight at
the bottom it's just not the case so
because that's just our frame of
reference our frame of reference is the
ones we see all the time also what
happened when I was a kid I was treated
like what what he says he was treated
you know what I mean I was treated like
an ugly kid I even say it when I was a
kid I was an ugly kid uh because I was
also invisible right but being invisible
is actually being
uh being average sometimes you're not
ugly it's just that the people around
you are just
silent so they don't don't voice their
thing out and the people are are voicing
they're voicing the ugly but the people
that are attracted or whatever they just
don't don't voice it out because of sh
whatever not so you only believe one
thing and our brain also our brain as
human beings we always often sometimes
focus on negative most of the time we
focus on the negative even if there's a
bunch of positive we have all these
comments all these positive comments
that that one negative comment is going
to get at you so you disregard all the
the positive comments did you tell me
that you had some times where some girls
approached you and try to hit on you or
just like n you're lying
because of the lived experience in the
past but yes absolutely right right so
that doesn't mean that you weren't
necessarily invisible it's like first
off it's terrifying to go and approach a
crush cuz I know I I was a giant [__]
when I was in school so there's probably
a lot of people who did like you or did
find you cute or attractive or whatever
but they just didn't even think about
approaching but the ones that were loud
were the one that thought I was ugly
it's really easy to say I was ugly so
was I really ugly maybe not I don't even
think you necessarily were
invisible yeah abely there was people
who seen you you know what just like you
said they just weren't voicing it they
were voicing it so you have to take that
and accountability accountability and
stuff like that so yeah that's is just a
VI what I got to say that's a good good
observations I like that I like that
what you said in regards to what
happened to you as a kid doesn't
necessarily Define you today um that's
all for today's video Let's know what
you guys think in the comments below do
you guys agree disagree with us do yall
think this guy's really ugly I don't
know let us know